bonjour françois patriat merci beaucoup
d'attentes invités politiques ce matin
on vous êtes sénateur de la côte-d'or
président du groupe rdpc le groupe des
sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane vers
des mondes jean-stéphane bonjour bonjour
stéphane qui dirige le bureau parisien
du journal ouest france
on va commencer par ce qui fait
l'actualité de ces dernières heures le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer requis est sous le feu
des critiques françois patriat il était
en vacances à ibiza lorsqu'il a annoncé
le nouveau protocole sanitaire la veille
de la rentrée un protocole que les
enseignants que les directeurs d'école
attendait à ce qu il a commis une faute
politique
le ministre je ne le pense pas le
ministre était en vacances il était à
une heure de paris je connais bien jean
michel blanquer je sais qu'il est au
travail en permanence et je ne doute pas
qu'il était en lien à la fois avec le
gouvernement avec le premier ministre et
avec tous ces services donc il a préparé
la rentrée pour avoir une école ouverte
ce que selon vous il n'ya pas de
problème les directeurs d'école je
rentrais souvent plutôt de leurs
vacances la ministre était en vacances à
ibiza quand il a annoncé le protocole
n'y a pas de souci pour beaucoup plus
tôt ça je ne sais pas côté 1 les
enseignants j'imagine que les
enseignants n'aimerais pas qu'on parle
de leurs vacances
j'imagine qu'il n'ya pas qu'on en parle
faisons pas de bon
sens et nationales que je pense voyait
non je pense que ce matin c'est une
instrumentalisation contre un ministre
qui est à la barre qui suit les dossiers
et en fin de compte si les décisions ont
été tardives c'est-à-dire proche de la
rentrée c'est parce que les décisions
des instances sanitaires il est pris de
décision sont faits sur des bases qui
ont été émis par le monde médical et
qu'elles ont été remises in fine et au
dernier moment après des arbitrages
parce que le gouvernement souhaitait
alléger le plus possible mais que les
instances sanitaires on se dit qu'on
prenne des précautions maintenir les
écoles ouvertes oui contrairement à ce
qu'aurait voulu d'autre qu'on les ferme
parce que c'était mieux pour les enfants
c'est mieux pour les enfants c'est mieux
aussi pour l'ensemble de l'activité dans
notre pays je ne pense pas que le
ministre et en l'occurrence commune
quand vous parlez de
l'instrumentalisation vous pensez à qui
en de manière précise plus précise
l'opposition de gauche ou à des
fondations prigent qui dit qu'un journal
d'extrême gauche qui sort la formation
qui lâche un vote d'experts jeunes
d'extrême gauche c'est médiapart
information qui a été confirmée par un
ministère de l'éducation nationale il ya
parts qui le sort donc vous dire que
c'est parce qu'il a sorti ensuite
aujourd'hui j'ai compris qu'il y avait
contre michel blanc caire une bronca qui
va au delà de la du traitement de l'acné
la crise sanitaire parce que l'instinct
nombre d'enseignants enseignants n'ont
pas aimé les réformes qui ont été faites
la réforme sur le bac dédoublement pour
moi je pense que le bilan de jean michel
blanquer est et à bon bilan un ministre
qui tient cinq ans à sa place et qu'il
était beaucoup soutenu par une partie
des enseignants pendant tout ce
quinquennat donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il faut regarder le travail qu'il a fait
et la mission qu'ils assument celle de
faire en sorte que le virus circule
moins et que les enfants aillent à
l'école mais quand vous entendez ce
matin la gauche qui demandent sa
démission et yannick jadot il parle de
mépris et d'irresponsabilité olivier
faur dit que la confiance n'est plus
possible et ce qui peut se maintenir a
nommé l'outrance des oppositions
politiques qui savent qu'ils sont dans
un navire que de toute façon n'ira pas
au port parce qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui cette gauche
explose et qui sait très bien qu'elle ne
participera pas au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle et qui dans ce mode même
temps de façon péremptoire entend dicter
sa conduite du gouvernement et aussi
bien olivier faure je suis ado sont pas
quand même suffisamment déjà les bières
des perdreaux de l'année pour penser on
fait démissionner à ministre à 90 jours
de la présidentielle et quand les
syndicats appellent à une nouvelle
journée d'action dans l'éducation
nationale ils sont même type de calcul
pour vous il ya quand même un problème
sur le jeune homme demande c'était avant
celle ci a une part de responsabilité
j'entends qu'il y ait des difficultés
j'entends que tout n'ait pas été fait
j'entends que le protocole est dur à
mettre en place qu'il est dur pour tout
le monde pour les parents pour les ans
pour les enseignants pour tous il est
dur pour tout le monde je m'entends bien
de la ajouté ajouté je le dire de la
crise à la crise je trouve pas que ce
soit très bien normal parce que on est
encore dans une période aujourd'hui où
c'est grave vous avez vu hier 3500 une
nouvelle hospitalisation
452 enfants à l'hôpital 4 300 morts hier
si on pense qu'on est en pendant le
palier que ça va mieux ce que j'entends
dire là depuis depuis depuis quelques
jours c'est encore très grave et le
ministre a raison de vouloir prendre des
mesures qui protègent ça veut dire qu il
faut pas de nouveau protocole celui
annoncé dernièrement par jean castex et
il faut plus rechange et ne souhaite pas
que je pense qu'il faut aller vers un
allègement au fur et à mesure que nous
aurons passé pique ça ira mieux je pense
paquet de mesures à prendre pour le tour
si
oui le parlement a voté dimanche le
texte instaurant le pass vaccinale mais
il n'entrera pas en application avant
quelques jours est ce que c'est un échec
pour le gouvernement ou le fait que le
pass soit pas opérationnel dès le 15 n'a
pas grande importance finalement je vais
vous vous reposer un peu la question
autrement je vous écoute est ce que non
c'est ça non mais je veux dire comment
comment je la vois moi je pense que une
opposition qui applaudit parce qu'on
suspend les débats à minuit une
exposition qui se réjouit parce que le
débat va durer plus longtemps une
opposition qui dispose des centaines de
800 amendements répétitif pour bloquer
le débat une opposition qui au sénat ne
cire ne veut pas siéger le vendredi et
le samedi parce que il faut naître
connaître la sérénité qu'on repousse de
quatre jours le débat alors qu'on est en
pleine crise une opposition qui fait
exploser un avec un tweet malheureux la
cmp pour reprendre encore deux jours de
débats alors effectivement si l'objectif
de l'opposition c'est de créer des
embûches au gouvernement là c'est réussi
je m'entends comme je l'entends comme
tels que le gouvernement a dit que le
pass serait serait opérationnelle de 15
on aurait pu très bien être le 15 si on
avait si on a des siéger la semaine
dernière la nation n'avait siégé la cmp
le week-end dernier le texte serait voté
alors pour vous c'est la faute aux
oppositions mais est ce que vous
entendez quand ils disent sur un texte
pareil on a besoin de temps on a besoin
et battre c'est le rôle du parlement
vous l'entendez ça pour aboutir à quoi
aujourd'hui le texte du gouvernement tel
qu'il a été présenté il passe in extenso
mais ici on a passé on n'a pas ces 450
amendements pour arriver à quoi à rien
parce qu'on n'a pas été capable
d'avancer avec les sénateurs et quand
ils ont voulu aboutir à aboutir à un
accord le président du groupe l'a fait
exploser donc moi je veux bien mais le
gouvernement lui
comment
bruno retailleau cette île épiphénomène
de la commission mixte paritaire avait
souhaité que l'ump a réussi alors
qu'elle n'est pas terminée alors là si
ça avait été l'inversé alors j'aurais
entendu le président et senna j'aurais
entendu bruno retailleau pousser des
cris d'orfraie nancy vous à vous dire
que on était dans un petit jeu de
guéguerre pour plutôt gêné le
gouvernement et les autres et je lui ai
laissé inspirer par la présidentielle ou
non mais bien entendu on met sur le
tracé replantation non mais ça a été ça
a été le cas où ce n est quand même au
cours on l'a vu sur les grandes réformes
de l'état et cetera qu'on a voulu faire
c'est plus que ça c'est le jeu normal de
l'opposition qu'il y ait des débats je
l'entends des débats redondance et
inutile non mais oh bull tout cela le
problème ce n'est pas de savoir si le
gouvernement a été ennuyée embêter au
bout de tout cela c'est de savoir que le
pape va quidam n'est pas mieux on va en
place plutôt qu'ils perdent ce que le
poste final un double rôle le premier
temps ce péché la circulation du virus
est le deuxième à l'état les forces et
les gens se faire vacciner voilà donc
plus y aura de gens vaccinés et imaginer
aujourd'hui à tout ce que qui veut
qu'ils prennent la partie des antilles
vax dans quelle situation aujourd'hui
serions nous si 80% des français n'a pas
été vaccinés mais du coup sûr le sur le
premier point si tenté qu'il empêche la
vaccination du virus que savait très
bien où pouvaient être vaccinés est
contaminée est ce que le fait qu'on
arrive au moment où la vague omicron
semble décroître du coup il n'arrive pas
trop tard ce pas actionnaire les skins
encore une utilité au moment où il sera
mise en jeu je vous le dis il à
l'utilité parce que d'abord malgré ce
qu'on dit le virus circule encore
beaucoup vous avez encore 300 milles
contamination par jour donc pas trop
tard un donc si on prend des mesures
restrictives pour que les gens ne soient
pas que les gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés
viennent contaminer
ou encore relancé le débat en deuxième
le kivu on a vu ce que cette crise
depuis deux ans qui vous dit ce qu'elle
sera dans un mois dans trois mois dans
quatre mois est ce qu'il aura pas à
nouveau variant alors
c'est parce vaccinale qui a pour but
d'inciter parce que depuis depuis qu'il
est mis en place dès le début il ya cinq
cent mille personnes primo vaccinés qui
ne sont pas aujourd'hui immuniser le
bien d'accord mais ce qu'on espère c'est
qu'on en aura 1 million un million et
demi qu'on aura plus de façon à réduire
la frange de la population qui peuvent
donner des variants ou qui peut
communiquer parce que c'est vrai vous
avez raison de dire quand on est
vaccinés on peut transmettre mais
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins les
parlementaires socialistes juste un
dernier mot là dessus les parlementaires
socialistes et insoumis ont eu raison de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel pour
vous pour ce texte qui touche quand même
liberté je pense que c'est l'ultime
l'ultime manipulations pour tenter de
repousser le la mise en place du pass
vaccine r il dira en sorte qu'on a bien
ennuyé le gouvernement alors que le
gouvernement il n'a pas besoin d'être
aidé il a besoin plutôt d'être une idée
soutenue parce qu'on le port édition ne
soutiendra pas toujours elle dit qu'elle
veut tu le passes mais le votent
différemment elle le fait reculer donc
demain je pense que c'est une ultime
effectivement manoeuvre dit la plupart
pas dilatoire mais pour repousser
l'application par les dessins n'est pas
un très grand voilà vous ne parlez
manoeuvre sur fond de présidentielle est
ce qu'une dégradation de la situation
sanitaire ou
l'impression que la crise aurait été mal
gérée par exemple pourrait pourrait
faire du tort à emmanuel macron dans le
cadre de la course à l'elysée je pense
que ce que je vois sur le terrain de ce
que j'entends chaque semaine et même si
c'est que le président a plutôt fait le
job alors on veut repartir a toujours
des premiers épisodes des tests d'image
au début où tout le monde tâtonnait mais
ce que je crois que c'est que le
président a su prendre les décisions
quand il le fallait parfois même à
contre-courant de ce que préconisent les
scientifiques souvenez vous il ya un an
jour pour jour tout le monde disait
qu'il fallait il fallait à l'époque est
fermé le pays totalement président a dit
non on continue pour le pays vive
l'activité je pense que il a eu raison
parce que d'un côté les français
maintenant sont à 90 pour s'en protéger
que l'économie est repartie
que le plan de relance qui ont été faits
pendant ce temps et qui ont anticipé sur
le plan du chômage sur le pour la
croissance ont permis aux jeunes d'avoir
une croissance que nous n'avions jamais
jusqu'à présent autour des six que le
taux de chômage a baissé pendant ce
temps et que je vais dire maintenant la
france est pratiquement
pratiquement couvert thé vaccinés c'est
la persistance de la pandémie qui
l'empêchent qui l'empêchent
d'officialiser sa candidature à sa
propre succession le président il est
élu pour cinq ans et pas pour quatre ans
et demi vous avez compris qu'il ya des
sangles
d'accords mets donc y aurait plus de
président pendant trois mois est ce que
vous pensez qu'au moment we r quand je
vois le président quitté sur l'industrie
du futur qui annonce les projets la 25e
l'icône des projets de
réindustralisation 10000 emplois créés
cette année les investissements qui sont
plus fort dans ce pays alors quel est le
problème de l'europe qui la présidence
de l'europe alors quel est le problème
du terrorisme à gérer alors qu'est le
problème c'est qu'on est mal gérée mais
je suis plus content il va devoir se
déclarer dans les jours qui viennent
avant la mi fait mais ça veut dire que
quand il sera déclaré sera plus
président non ça veut dire non mais vous
savez ça veut dire que je pense que
d'abord je sais pas si c'est la mi
février à titre personnel moi je
tremblais je pense plutôt que c'est la
fin février
je me souviens de français habitant au
mois de mars 1 j'ai aussi un chirac qui
l'a fait la même époque et personne je
me souviens de ce que disait valérie
pécresse en 2011 elle disait que le
président sarkozy avait raison de
retarder le plus possible sa déclaration
parce qu'il y avait après la crise de
2008 des sujets importants dans le pays
et si on ne fait rien pour vous et si
vous deviez le conse le conseiller c'est
quoi la meilleure foule la meilleure
façon de se présenter pour un président
qui veut briguer sa succession pour ça
que je crois que ce serait la plus
simple possible c'est alors toute
affaire de montrer comment ils entendent
à l'action de montrer à la fois de
trouver la façon de dire voilà mon bilan
et je pense que la majorité nous en
sommes fiers je pense que les français
voient le travail qui a été fait et dans
le même temps voilà la projection j'ai
pour l'avenir le programme mais ce gars
là ne risque pas même de payer son
ambiguïté dans les urnes activement les
français vont en avoir marre du
président-candidat candidat était vrai
pour toutes les présidentielles tout
tout présidentielle à par poitiers eu le
décès de georges pompidou une alternance
bien donc ça a été vrai aujourd'hui le
président ce n'est que demain et à ce
très beau 1 quelle strasbourg grand
discours sur l'europe et il me semble
que sur le plan sanitaire que sur le
plan d'immigration que la sécurité que
sur le plan des finances que sur le plan
de la relance industrielle c'est
important alors ils devraient plus aller
là bas parce qu'il serait candidat parce
que s'il était candidat le directeur
d'ethos stop stop là vous n'avez pas le
droit mais il est président j'allais
vous dire c'est entre guillemets le
privilège du président de pouvoir
continuer à gouverner dans le même temps
de faire des propositions aux français
il vous a pas échappé qu'il en a fait
tout à l'heure vous en avez cité
d'ailleurs qu'elles ont été mal
interprétés j'ai vu sur l'université on
pourra y revenir si vous le souhaitez on
peut revenir à l'irlande sur le fait
qu'il envisage la fin de la gratuité
l'univers non il a jamais le président n
a jamais dit qu'il voulait augmenter les
droits d'entrée à l'université n'a pas
dit ça j'ai regardé hier à l'élysée le
verbatim n'a pas dit ça il a dit qu'il
faut que maintenant les angles notre
université s'élève on aille vers
l'excellence l'excellence dans les
grandes écoles l'excellence à côté la
différenciation entre les universités
que les bourses augmente collègues
bourse augmente par ailleurs et que les
étudiants deviennent des apprentis des
apprentis acteurs de la vie et de la vie
active voilà un mot sur eric zemmour qui
a été condamné hier pour provocation à
la haine condamne évidemment
mille euros pour avoir qualifié les
mineurs isolés de voleurs et d'assassins
il va faire appel et il dénonce je cite
une condamnation idéologique et stupide
il est urgent de chasser les idéologies
des tribunaux dit-il qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces propos je pense qu'il est
surtout urgent de chasse et l'idéologie
d'eric zemmour choix c'est ça ou la
première c'était mort j rétrograde moisi
d'une france du passé glorifié par eric
zemmour avec tous les travers qu'on lui
connaît à côté moi moi j'ai pas envie de
débattre avec eric zemmour l'outrance la
transformation la falsification de
l'histoire telle qu'elle est faite
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que monsieur
zemmour n'a pas captivé fasciné un
public pendant des années sur les médias
avec des propositions qui allaient dans
le fond ce dès fois de ce que ressentent
une partie des français qui se sentent
isolés déclassé oublier menacée
j'entends bien mais je pense que c'est
pas ce ressort là qu'il faut donner aux
français que c'est pas le ressort de la
peur et de la nostalgie du passé mais
c'est plutôt le ressort de l' envie
celle c'est le ressort de l'action c'est
le ressort du progrès qu'il faut qu'il
faut demain il ne parle pas des
problèmes sociaux il ne parle pas des
problèmes économiques d'abord je pense
que je sais pas si il est spécialiste en
la matière je ne le crois pas mais par
ailleurs on voit bien qu'il a une
obsession celle du grand emplacement
quand vous dites juste j'ai pas envie de
les battre à eric zemmour ça veut dire
que ça ne serait pas un problème pour
vous qu'une pipe est candidat eric
zemmour ou est-ce qu'il doit être
candidat parce qu'ils représentent
quelque chose dans la société je ne
doute pas qu'il aura ses parrainages
parce que je crois qu'il y aura parmi la
droite et même parmi les républicains
des gens qui sont de façon directe ou
indirecte faire en sorte qu'ils les
aient ces parrainages
aujourd'hui il est l'allié il est
l'allié objectif de mener 13 que les
choses soient claires ce que rêve
républicain c'est que monsieur zemmour
prenne le maximum de bois madame le pen
pour assurer au second tour la place de
madame pécresse quelque chose on va pas
être dupe on va pas dire que je
l'entendais je le sais je le vois autour
de moi mais j'allais dire ça fait partie
du jeu politique
quel que soit le candidat qui affrontera
emmanuel
moire sais pas je pense qu'il y aura des
mers proche des républicains il faut
dire que je que je manque ce n'est pas
vrai mais je vois bien ce qui se dit pas
le discours en tout cas je vous
d'acheter sur le terrain moi dès
mercredi sur le terrain qu'ils avaient
la main libre pour le faire et qui
aurait pas de sanctions voilà donc non
je crois qu'à chaque foyer ce cinéma au
parrainage et de surcroît je suis moi à
tout prix pour que le parrainage soit
transparent j'exigerai même ça veut dire
qu'on nous maintenir les modèles à 48
mines il ya 48 milles par impossible de
42000 pop si on peut pas en trouver
mille là c'est 500 1 500 mais quand je
vois qu'elles sont souvent quand je vois
qu'il ya des candidats qui vont faire un
pour cent qui ont leur parrainage
philippe tout voilà et des gens qui au
fait ça veut dire que pour vous il faut
augmenter le ça il faut passer de 500 à
1000 moi je moi je pense que je pense
que le tri au départ par le moyen
qu'avait imaginé le général de gaulle à
l'époque
parce que on va bien il ya des clients
il ya des candidats qui a 10 12 % ou 15
% de nos peines disent qu'ils ont des
difficultés il ya des candidats ainsi ce
tweet surtout que ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose quand vous avez les
appareils politiques avec beaucoup
d'élus locaux c'est facile avoir lu par
yoji socialiste la république à baulon
facilement on voit bien ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas à côté non non pas si c'est
pas la même chose donc
est ce que est ce que vous êtes en train
de dire qu'il faudrait faire le tri
autrement que par les élus non vous avez
des propositions par exemple pour dire
il faudrait que qu'un camp que qu'un
candidat puisse se présenter s'il avait
le soutien de 150 mille citoyens par
exemple ça ce serait une bonne formule
sam japon dans un patio nécessairement
par les gels je pense qu'il faut y
réfléchir il faut effectivement en tout
cas l'aja j'approuve ce qu'avait fait
françois hollande en la matière de
rendre de rendre les signatures
publiques savent c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'avant c'est le cade et sont
totalement public mais puis 2016 depuis
l'élection de 2010 est totalement elle
et sachez que aujourd'hui je cherche à
faire en sorte à ma petite échelle quel
président s'il etc s'il est candidat et
je le souhaite et je souhaite qu'ils le
soient c'est bien et suffisamment de
signatures aura bien d'autres la timba
pas du tout mais qui n'a même pas
juste un mot on n'y a pas de doute parce
que vous avez évoqué les chercher et je
les trouve facilement vous avez évoqué
regza moore et les républicains est ce
qu'on peut faire un énorme on peut avoir
droit à un petit point sur la gauche
l'état de la gauche dès gauche et des
écologistes quel regard portez vous
rassure vous voulez vous avez longtemps
été socialiste riche si je voulais un
peu vulgaire je vous dirais que c'est la
foire à la saucisse
voilà je le dis ce matin comme une
plaisanterie pour mettre un peu
d'ambiance moi je me sens quand je vois
des candidats arnaud montebourg je
connais bien et les bourguignons la
remonte tada déclarations fracassantes
qui la radio pour cent quand je vois
madame hidalgo qui attendait d'être
entre autres un vous reproche pas madame
hidalgo et madame pécresse qui sont
présidentes et une paris il ya beaucoup
de travail et de la région ile de france
à quelques millions d'habitants qui se
promène tous les jours partout en france
en europe partout avec une personne ne
reproche qui ne sont pas longs posts
personne ne leur dit alors là on
reprocher à ce matin à ce que vous me
disiez au ministre l'éducation mais eux
ils sont engraissés partout et on perd
ce père personne personne ne dit rien
alors les toits de la gauche
lance le jour où j'ai gfi j'étais vous
savez j'étais rocardien gesppe ligne à
strauss kahnien donc j'ai trouvé en
emmanuel macron quelqu'un qui pouvait
enfin faire en sorte que la démo social
démocratie telle que je la comprends
réussissent et elle a réussi et avec
l'idée que on pouvait rassembler mieux
les français pour pouvoir faire des
réformes
en fait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui parce
que regarder le fait qu' il ne soient
d'accord sur rien assure l'accueil
sécurité pas sur l'immigration pas sur
l'europe pas sur la société les les
candidats de gauche entre le prg les
socialistes les écologistes les
communistes n'ont aucun accord sur les
grands défis dans notre pays aujourd'hui
il ya désaccord total avec un grand
parti comme le parti socialiste auquel
j'ai adhéré en 1975 un camp 1075 il
avait à l'époque un leader il avait des
idées il avait un programme il avait des
femmes et les hommes qui le soutenaient
aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'une division une
multiplication une balkanisation de
candidats qui ne franchissent pas 5% et
qu'il voudrait donner des leçons au
monde entier en politique pour vous
c'est l'hallali du ps c'est fini moi je
me souviens de vous sur ce plateau en
2017 ou 2018 vous disiez le parti
socialiste est promis à devenir le
l'équivalent des radicaux c'est à dire
avoir une érosion très lente dans le
temps alors je ne leur est rien comme
une finale je pense que le parti
socialiste de 2022 c'est celui de la sci
fi haut de 70 donc c'est plus radicaux
et 7 non mais c'est 70 voilà où on en
est tombé temps bien 5% et souvenez-vous
que de faire en 1969 gps gfc la campagne
de records cette année là avait fait 5 %
dans vos là où on en est aujourd'hui si
une gauche se reconstruit d'aumale se
fera autour d'un programme de débats
d'idées d'un leader et donc qui le
porteront allez on va parler ce qui se
passe dans votre majorité puisque
edouard philippe a suspendu sa
participation à la maison commune après
la fusion avortée entre agir le parti de
franck riester et horizons partie des
douars fidh et pourtant autorisé dans
les statuts de cette maison commune
franck riester dit cagire n'a pas été
autorisée à fusionner sur ordre de l'est
et c'est le rôle des manuels matheron
s'occuper de ça il ya un problème entre
emmanuel macron inler figuier d'abord je
pense pas qu'ils aient eu d'ordre lisais
je ne pense pas les réunions participer
je n'ai pas entendu qui que ce soit de
l'elysée le représentant du chef de
l'état lui-même pire cela je n'ai pas
entendu maintenant que halak entre deux
familles de la droite aujourd'hui un
bien que elle souhaite elle souhaitait
fusionner pas fusionner c'est un
problème entre eux de leadership de
moyens il n'existe
alors est-ce que ce que j'entends
surtout de ce qui s'est passé hier il y
aura un midi je participerai au déjeuner
de la majorité deux ensembles citoyens
avec les 1 philippe je sais pas si mon
fils et j'ai vu aujourd'hui qu'ils
auraient elles ont semblé les chefs de
groupe les représentants des chefs de
partis pardon et des chefs de groupe qui
sont présents donc ce que j'entends ce
que j'entends et ce que je lis c'est
qu'elle doit re philippe d'hier écrit il
n'y a aucun problème je serai loyal je
soutiendrai le président la république
les affaires de boutique je veux pas
être emmerdés qui sera loyal
effectivement à l'oeil et canon 106
résidents alors oui ça il l'a dit très
clairement mais en même temps si vous me
permettez l'expression il dit qu'il
suspend sa participation à la maison
comme les lits suspend un ensemble
citoyens de c'est quand même un problème
il suspend il suspend pour des raisons
qui sont à bord donc en suspens en
attendant quoi il veut faire pression
sur ton va t en parler a mis un set à
discuter avec
non je n'ai pas de bon je sais pas ce
qui se passe en coulisses pas vous dire
ce que je sais c'est le lien est
maintenu avec edouard philippe j'ai vu
hier les responsables du mouvement
qu'ils m'ont dit qu'ils avaient qu'ils
avaient appelé gier edouard philippe
plusieurs fois ces jours derniers il
doit avoir des investitures qu'elle
estime que le contenu horizons
il doit être en mesure de pouvoir former
un groupe à l'assemblée pour vous alors
moi j'aime pas aujourd'hui je supporte
pas que dans cette campagne électorale
on langage avec déjà des arrière pensées
pour 2027 pour certains et puis pour les
clans je dis pas pour les tout le monde
doit pas oublier bien entendu qui a dit
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont cité 2027
et pas seulement edouard philippe
d'ailleurs edouard philippe ne l'a
jamais cité elle n'a jamais cité en
lui-même mais on entend bien des
supporters des gens qui le font c'est le
meilleur il d'autre candidat il n'y a
pas que lui le ghana doit des ministres
économie de l'intérieur et d'autres y en
a d'autres qui pourraient penser
vingt-sept dont j'entends bien mais
comprends moi je pense qu'il faut se
fixer
sur l'élection présidentielle et sur le
premier tome est sûre le premier tour
nos regards et nos énergies doivent être
totalement concentré sur le 10 avril
déjà déjà prospecté le futur vous êtes
sauvés n'étions pas là notre peau de
l'ours avant de l'avoir tué vous
connaissez justin un dernier mouvement
se battre et à son tour le 10 avril
après moi je donne un dernier mot sur
cette maison comme une escalade du plomb
dans l aile avec la suspension de la
participation des leurs philippe pascal
en moins d'intérêt ce nom parce que non
parce qu'elle appelle plomb dans la tête
et non parce que je veux dire
jeudi jeffrey gérait dijon on va faire
une rencontre avec avec des élus avec
des gens dans la rue en faire du compost
on ira on va faire on va faire une
réunion jeudi vendredi et samedi où il y
aura horizon agir ou ignorer s'ils
viennent avec nous horizon vient des
clauses à une manifestation où il y aura
le modem où il y aura les radicaux où il
y aura en marche une dernière à tous
ensemble sur le terrain une dernière
question rapidement puisqu'une sénat
examine demain le texte sur le
prolongement du délai légal d'olivier
vous ne l'aviez pas inscrit dans leur
niche parlementaire c'est le
gouvernement du coup qu'il a remis à
l'ordre du jour à l'autre devrait trait
à notre demande les battre et nous nous
sentons bien entendu le groupe le groupe
lensois n'ont cédé que sur 7 sur ces
textes là
le groupe air des pays comme d'autres
groupes d'ailleurs laisse la liberté de
voix tout seuls 23
je vous dirai pas ce que j'ai une
réunion de groupe dans l'heure qui vient
qui veut qui votera ce texte je pense
que a eu deux ou trois peut-être deux
abstentions il y aura peut-être deux
abstentions ne pense pas qu'ils aient de
votre compte mail sera voté moi je le
vois très bien entendu mais rien que
nous avons voté le passé litter y
compris aussi n'dam même été transformé
parce que nous voulons qu'il réussisse
merci françois patriat merci d'avoir
essayé notre invité
[Musique]